good morning hickets tuesday you'll note
that puff levels remain at near record
levels so recently my daughter was
discussing how she did not like the
cornmeal casing on her school lunch corn
dog and
two things occurred to me first i
realized that almost all of my
conversations over the last year have
been
either about it or at least shaped by it
like even when i'm talking with friends
and family about something other than
the pandemic and its direct consequences
the pandemic
is still essential to the geometry of
the conversation
like when we're talking about politics
we're also talking about the virus when
we're talking about school or
work or really anything we're also
talking about the virus but this
conversation about the corn dog could
have happened two years ago or
five years ago or really any time
because children have been pulling the
cornmeal off of corn dogs and school
lunches since time immemorial like i'm
pretty sure that such a scene is
depicted on a grecian urn
i didn't say any of that to my kid
though because to call attention to the
pandemiclessness of the conversation
would have been to add the pandemic to
the conversation what i said was
you know your uncle hank loves corn dogs
and then my daughter said
does he and it was in that moment hank
that i realized how successfully and
profoundly you have rebranded yourself
like in 2010
you were a goofball corn dog enthusiast
and today you are a tick-tock sensation
who is among the world's leading science
communicators two phrases by the way
tick-tock sensation and science
communicator i had
literally never heard in 2010. i guess
broadly speaking there are two
approaches to rebranding you can take
the planter's peanuts path where you
announce a dramatic shift by having a
commercialized funeral for your animated
spokes nut and then rebrand with a hip
baby spokes nut and then there are the
slow motion over time
reimaginings that often happen without
us much noticing them until we
look back into the past like i have this
experience sometimes when i'm walking in
the woods and find what appears to be an
ancient
beer can but upon close inspection it
turns out it isn't ancient it's from
like 1994 when i was not only alive
but sometimes drinking beer and those of
us who've left behind a lot of artifacts
online over time from tweets to youtube
videos are beginning to have a similar
experience like when i look at march
2007 vlogbrothers me
that person is both familiar and quite
distant
obviously that guy and i have a lot in
common but we're also really different
like if you ask me to tell you
one essential thing about myself the
most important thing it would be that
i'm
a parent something 2007 me wasn't 2007
me wasn't the author of the fault in our
stars or
resident of indianapolis or a supporter
of afc wimbledon or the co-founder of
crash course or best friends with chris
and marina or someone who enjoyed
jogging and on and on and on and hank
2007 you wasn't a father or an author or
the ceo of an educational media company
you were a goofy youtuber who loved corn
dogs
i mean here's how successfully you've
branded away from corn dogs hank there
was a corn dog hank
t-shirt to go with the pizza john
t-shirt pizza john
still very much here corn dog hank
forgotten to history
all right this video has been all over
the place we got to bring this to some
kind of conclusion okay
here we go big finish hank one thing you
explore really brilliantly in your
novels is how on the internet you can
never
fully leave your past behind because
everything you ever
said is in some ways still being said
when people read or hear an artifact
from your past
they are reading or hearing it in their
present
i don't really know how to navigate the
complexity of having pieces of my past
from books to tweets floating around
in other people's presence but when i
look at it
i look to you because we've never let
the fact that you're the younger brother
get in the way of you being the wise
older brother and it seems to me hank
that one of the ways you've staged
yourself
is by changing all that noted hank plus
corn dogs remains a great love story as
prominently noted in my 2021 vision
board hank i will see you on friday